well more elite athletes have been
wading into the controversial debate on
whether transgender competitors should
be able to compete in women's sport
some transgender athletes say that calls
to keep them out of the competition
amount to hate
speech but those leading the campaign
deny that being transphobic insisting
that they want to
protect the sport well let's talk now to
olympic swimmer and silver medalist
sharon davis who is backing the fair
play
women campaign and joins me now you have
been
called by the transgender cyclist rachel
mckinnon
a transphobe and somebody who shares
hate speech what do you say to that
well i can't stop her saying whatever
she wants to say at the end of the day
you know i'm still going to stick to my
point of view
is that unfortunately if you're a
transgender woman you would have spent a
fair bit of your life and puberty as a
man
or as a boy and you would have the male
benefits that that would give you and
that makes it an unfair playing field
for
for other women so i think this is just
about sport i don't think we need to get
personal i'm certainly not a transphobic
but she wants to say that as i say i
can't stop her
um i'm here to try and fight for for the
rights of women you know that want to
have a level playing field
uh she will argue another two supporter
will argue that that it isn't giving
trans women an unfair advantage that
they have to get their testosterone
levels down to a certain amount before
they're able to compete that they have
no natural advantage over women
why do you think they do
well i've already just kind of outlined
the fact that they go through puberty
um if a young boy goes through puberty
he has increased
lung capacity he has higher red blood
cell count he has a different skeletal
system
a smaller narrower pelvis which helps
certainly on a bike
he has muscle memory from the
testosterone that's been in his system
and the actual
amount that they have to reduce their
testosterone still makes it very high
compared to the average woman
so there's a lot of residual values that
carry on and therefore makes it unfair
you know we don't see transgender women
that that transition over to men
competing against men because they're at
a disadvantage
and then the opposite happens with women
they end up with an advantage and that's
what we're
we're not so happy about so we just want
to have open clear debates
um we want to get the authorities on
board we want to get the ioc to look at
this again
and we want to try and make sure that
it's all based on medical facts
how do you think the authorities can
deal with this better do you think they
have dealt with it particularly well up
to now
i think it's a bit fudged and i think
people have kind of pushed it under
the carpet and i think you know we don't
really want this to become a problem
before we have to sort it out we'd like
to try and
head it off at the pass if we can um
there are some situations in america
in 17 states um over there uh young boys
are allowed to compete if they identify
as women
up to the age of 18 without any chemical
intervention whatsoever that means that
includes not reducing their testosterone
so those girls are at a massive
disadvantage there are a couple of um
examples of people being involved in
combat sports where they have seriously
hurt their opposition
that's something we've got to talk about
as well so i think it is a big
a big issue um i think we need to be
very fair to the transgender community
this is not about
trying to cause problems i mean i think
they go through what is a very
challenging
stage in their life and we need to
support them but at the same time we
also need to support women in sport
there had there has been some
speculation that there are more women in
sport who would like to come
out and talk about this but that they're
concerned about doing so because they
fear that they will
possibly use sponsorship what are your
thoughts about that have you have you
had conversations with people who've
said actually i don't want to put my
head above the parapet
yeah many to be honest with you um quite
a lot of people
especially as you say people that are
competing at the moment they're worried
that their governing bodies were frowned
on it they're worrying that their
sponsors
will think it's not pc and they're not
allowed to do this and that's what i
think is wrong with this debate you know
why should we label someone that has a
different view from you as transphobic
um i just think this is open honest
debate nobody's having a go at anyone no
one is being rude i've tried very hard
on my twitter account to make sure that
anyone that's rude
i you know verbally tell them offer
being rude and and say i'm not involved
i'm not interested in you doing this
so i think it's it's really important
that we're we're just honest and open
and that we move forward the women's
sport has taken such great strides in
the last few years it would be a real
shame to see it take a step backwards
no transgender uh athletes have made it
have they for the olympics qualified for
the olympics let alone a medal so i
suppose
some would say that maybe they aren't
getting the
outages well yes some would say that
wouldn't they but ultimately um
it was like 2016 their rules were
changed from two years that you had to
have lower testosterone to only one year
so i think
there's a lot of talk about people that
will be involved in the 2020 olympic
games there's a volleyball
player in particular um that actually at
the moment that's doing incredibly well
but you know there is a definite
physical advantage to her and that is
our
whole point do you think this is going
to put
women off you're saying that that some
women in sport are afraid to speak out
do you think as you say there's been
such great strides in women's sport over
the last few years do you think that
there's the potential knock-on effect of
young
girls not necessarily wanting to take
part in some sports
yeah yes certainly scholarships in
america being lost
at the moment from young girls which
makes it very difficult for them
i think you know it does put them in a
difficult position i think obviously a
lot of people like myself have actually
come out paula radcliffe
nicola adams uh sally gunnell i mean
daley thompson who i spoke to and
actually just about everyone i speak to
has the same opinion and in fact most
people
that think about it sensibly have the
same opinion so i don't think that this
is this wave of hate or rage or goodness
knows not
i just think we need to be grown up
about this really and look at all the
medical facts
um there's actually been a couple of
people as i mentioned and have been
seriously hurt and that
that's dangerous okay sharon davis good
to talk to you thanks so much for
joining us today
you're welcome